hallo mein name ist bekommen wir heute
zu einem neuen video nicht alleine meine
damen sondern mit einem gab es so noch
nie auf einem kanal hat bestimmt über
bei der damen und herren mit alkohol
könne gar nicht wissen der castings das
war auf jeden fall rentiert bei falke
sich ein paar youtube fragen
beziehungsweise nicht nur youtube
sondern auch so instagram und so twitter
fragen über youtube auf jeden fall
herausgesucht hat und wir beide müssen
dann schätzen erklärt dass die fragen
und wir müssen schätzen setzen dass wir
gar nicht so cool ich bin habe ich echt
schlecht und ich bin noch viel
schlechter einschätzung auf jeden fall
müssen wir so sachen wie beispielsweise
wie viele vielleicht hat das video wie
viele auch über das video sofort und
direkt am weitesten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine vermutung oder so völliger
schwachsinn
[Musik]
30.000 reagiert das heißt gute woche
ich hab so angeht wie musik videos über
eine million ist er ich hab keine ahnung
ich darf das nicht unterschätzen sind
immer noch
für meinen sohn eines viel aus kann auch
sein dass die mitte genau das alte war
wie viele aufrufe hat julia auf jeden
fall
[Musik]
ich weiß ist dreifach wahrscheinlich
kopiert ich hoffe dass wieder
zurückgegangen
ich spüre wieder eine linke wange ich
gesagt okay da nicht so viele auf lukaku
ich habe da ich hab da sogar vor ein
paar monaten noch darauf reagiert aber
ich weiß nicht mehr genau diese aufrufen
wenn ich das jetzt auch noch gehalten da
gehe ich mir selber noch nicht
die videos am anfang weniger die jungs
haben dann in unternehmen werke aber das
erste video vielleicht berichte ich
gerade auch ein
[Gelächter]
ich habe mich richtig gefreut
trotz mehrfacher vor locker dabei wert
komme nie wieder vergessen mein eigenes
trikot und war um wie viel ist also man
nimmt kann sich leute die dem kino folgt
und den bau folgt und an der unterschied
also theoretisch wenn kiko 500 folgen
würde und bei 100
gut ich hab das wird nur erreicht wenn
ich wieder abbekommen hätten nicht mehr
auf mein leben gekommen ja ich wusste
wie viel hat die meisten abos instagram
fakt dass ich nicht glaube ich weil die
meisten aber ich weiß nicht wie viele
plätze nicht wir sind ok lass uns
probieren sie aber was sagen wir jetzt
bei 321 mit den namen und die anzahl
oder wie genau
[Musik]
2000 das ist richtig er hatte bei 130
daneben 270 folgte ihm folglich auch
instagram 2000 jahre später örtlich auch
bezahlt und ich habe dir hochlädt wenn
er jetzt gerade neu bild hochgeladen
diese zeichnung war der trotz regen über
hochgeladen
da bin ich einfach näher dran da stimmen
aber 2006
ich habe so gehofft hat mit karacho
kleider tragen eine gute strategie
stephan hocke war solide aber nicht wie
oft erwartet
1 200 na ja komplett marke locker hat
aber dass meine werke wie viele neuenahr
of shankly vor drei tagen gemacht also
wir nehmen das video jahre auf am
sonntag abos die vielen arbeiten 20
millionen heimatfest am 21 juli ich bin
überhaupt nicht in den statistiken
gerade du natürlich wieder hätte dort
kommt box nicht
[Gelächter]
ich habe das große zahl hat jetzt
irgendwas kranke 4000 abonnent oder
irgendwas an einem tag gemacht okay wenn
ich jetzt wieder mit max krieger wir
dürfen meine ganzen videos kommentieren
sie heißt mein lebensweg es da ja
kommentare hatte das neueste video also
das neueste video in der playlist mein
leben von jim benninger kommentare das
video ist die kontur der forscher sagen
ich weiß nie wie viele kommentare und
das aufrufen so was alles aber
kommentare kann ich nicht einschätzen
aber okay ich deutscher bezahle ich
glaub ich weiß was ein video das ist ich
weiß nicht wie das video für seine
eltern die weite welt übergreife kriege
freude dann wisst ihr das hier alles
kommentieren wir dürfen mit christian
klien
[Musik]
trägt auf jeden fall mal rock kanal aber
ich weiß nicht was wir gerade bei
importen aber die kam auch noch eine
gute idee und talent hier irgendwie fall
kutscher fragen und der verlierer im
backteig dazu diese abwechselnd eine ich
eine gigabit endlich von elf fragen habe
ich den bug bekommen werden kann ich
mich normalerweise eher weniger freude
das macht ihr vom video endlich gefallen
hat noch leichter oskar ist eine
beschreibung in der video beschreibung
verlinkt ihr wisst was die
kommentierende frau im auto gewartet ihr
haltet ihr vom video
ihr könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder jungen mannschaft setzt
sich jetzt für andere medien berlin nach
unendlichen die auch die glücklichen
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]